we want to thank Google's science
journal app for supporting PBS Digital
Studios imagine you had a time machine
and with the press of a button you could
transport yourself to your own 75th
birthday assuming you're still around
what do you hope to find yourself doing
writing your memoirs sailing around the
world partying in San Junipero very few
of us would answer cleaning toilets at a
fast food joint or begging for change on
the street no one wants their story to
end that way yet shockingly few of us
are taking the basic steps to avoid it
[Music]
the simple fact is that if we're lucky
to live long enough one day we will lose
our desire or physical ability to keep
earning a paycheck the older we get the
harder it becomes to maintain a rigid
work schedule and as modern medicine
allows us to live longer and longer the
time we expect to spend in retirement
might easily pass 30 years think about
that for a second 30 years without
income nervous yet good so how much
would you need to not spend those years
in abject poverty well that depends on
your personal needs standard of living
health issues etc but as a starting
point the AARP recommends that to
replace a $40,000 per year income for 30
years you'll need to start your
retirement with take a deep breath 1.18
million dollars if that number makes you
feel dizzy well you're not alone in one
survey Americans between 55 and 64
reported a median retirement savings of
a hundred and twenty thousand only 10%
of the amount advised by the AARP
another survey found that 75 percent of
Americans over 40 are behind on saving
for retirement and 28% over 55 have no
retirement savings at all there are many
factors that contribute into this
problem for one thing wage growth
declined in the 70s and 80s it picked
back up in the 90s but then the housing
boom convinced a lot of Americans to go
into debt to buy overpriced homes and
well we know how that turned out
we've also seen an increase in cultural
pressure to show visual displays of
wealth
a study published in the quarterly
Journal of economics suggests that
Americans are uniquely concerned about
seeming poor to others so they spend a
disproportionate amount on things like
shoes clothes and cars it's been great
business for designer labels and
advertisers not so much for our savings
accounts
lastly changes in government policies
have made it easier to not save money in
the past employees were automatically
enrolled in defined benefit plans with
preset funding amounts to match their
retirement needs today's workers have to
opt into retirement plans like 401 K s
and figure out for themselves how much
to set aside furthermore these plans are
often leaky meaning you're allowed to
remove funds which we maturely which
makes it easy to steal from your own
retirement does all this mean that
saving for retirement is hopeless and
you should just blow all your extra
dough on leasing a sports car
no it's still very possible to save up
large amounts of money on a modest
income the three special ingredients are
good markets compound interest and time
to show you how these elements work
together it's time to run the numbers
Betty is 30 years old and makes 50,000 a
year
she hasn't saved a dime for retirement
yet but this year she's decided to start
between the amount she's gonna save into
her Roth IRA 401k at work and her 401k
match she's putting away six hundred
twenty-five dollars a month or 75
hundred a year that's 15 percent of her
income which many experts recommend as a
good savings target at this rate by the
time she's 65 Betty will have personally
deposited two hundred sixty two thousand
five hundred dollars into her retirement
account impressive but still a long way
from the million dollars plus she'll
need to retire but now we add our
special ingredients over the last 90
years the stock market has grown an
average of nine point eight percent per
year but let's assume a little less than
that say seven point five percent if
Betty can put together a decent
portfolio she can expect her savings to
grow by an average of seven point five
percent per year as long as Betty
doesn't touch that account the dividends
and interest she earns will generate
even more dividends and interest and
over time her savings don't just
increase in a straight line they grow
exponentially
so by the time she's 65 that two hundred
sixty two thousand five hundred of her
original money has ballooned to over one
point two million dollars
nice job Betty a couple things to keep
in mind with this scenario it's very
likely that goods and services will cost
more in the future due to inflation
however it's also very likely that a
thirty-year-old like Betty will see her
salary increase as she gains more
experience and skill if she sticks to
that same 15 percent of her salary she
can expect to have even more set aside
in retirement what if you're older than
Betty and getting a late start well that
may mean you need to set aside more of
your paycheck say 20 or 25 percent or
you may have to wait until your 70s to
retire either of these options is better
than doing nothing or counting on
winning the lottery there are many other
factors that can change your specific
situation inheritances social security
pensions medical conditions if you're
not sure where to begin you can seek out
the help of a finance
a planner who's a sworn fiduciary they
can outline a plan that fits your needs
and show you that preparing for
retirement is not as intimidating as you
may think you don't have to be in a
shuffleboard or bird watching to expect
a little time off and your golden years
and some people want to work as long as
they can but everyone wants the power to
decide that for themselves especially
after a lifetime of hard work of course
if you do manage to get access to a time
machine you can always fall back on the
old sports Almanac retirement plan and
that's our two cents thanks to Google
for supporting PBS Digital Studios their
mobile apps science journal lets you
take notes and measure scientific
phenomena such as light sound and motion
using your phone tablet or Chromebook
you can find activity ideas and
additional information on their website
at Chico forward slash science journal
you
[Music]